at the height of your heroin abuse yeah
okay yeah you had a closet in your house
where you like to go in that closet and
vomit i like to go in the in the closet
and do drugs because when you're
especially on cocaine you're getting
paranoid you want to be in a confined
place so it became my little ritual
place
but i wouldn't vomit in the closet i
would somehow make it to the
bathroom i see but listen here's the
thing okay heroin makes you throw up
right cocaine when you inject it makes
you throw up so you were injecting
i was injecting i was smoking i was
doing the whole thing and you were
buying drugs in bulk in other words you
were a smart drug addict what i call a
smart drug addict because if you got the
kind of money you do why don't you just
buy a bunch of drugs so you have them
there like a carton of cigarettes you
know if you're a cigarette smoker you
get a carton when you go out
why be so tied to your heroin dealer
everybody see him every day i mean if
you're gonna be saying that you're a
smart drug addict is kind of like
it's kind of like saying when someone
said to me the day they go you know
you're the brains of motley crew
i was like you know what i mean if
you're going to be a drug addict you
might as well have a supply so you're
not constantly chasing some deal dealers
aren't the most reliable people in the
world are they yeah you think yeah i
mean they're tough to get a hold of it
but you keep throwing up from these
drugs you don't ever get used to them it
just depends you know the the coke
almost always makes you cute is that
right look at this in your book i'm
gonna read a couple of statements you
gotta you gotta you gotta comment on it
this is the only place that i've done
any type of press or anything where you
can actually read my book listen to this
my new addiction is drinking tons of
water right before i shoot coke then
puking it all up in the jacuzzi as my
head explodes into the stratosphere why
not i'm engaged in a dance of death in
this house wow um you you would drink
tons of water it's all about puking and
doing drugs yeah well here's you know
what
i don't see where the enjoyment is in
that statement there's no enjoyment in
addiction yeah that's the thing it's
like i try to talk to these kids about
this and i say there is no enjoying hell
because you're just trying to feel good
yeah you're just trying to nurture
something that if you don't take care of
it you're going to feel like you're
you're dying so that's the problem with
addiction you know and if you if you
figure out what it is that's making you
get into the addiction it's easier to
get
out of the addiction even though the
physical withdrawal of it is horrible
and painful when you shoot heroin you
have to mix the heroin with water and
boil it up and all that right china
white water persian lemon okay it's like
a cooking show
why then you're standing in your house
you're a wealthy man you can take sink
water and mix your heroin
why did you use toilet water
the water from a toilet to mix your
heroin with oh because that was at a
denny's
you were at denny's i was driving to
rehearsal on a motorcycle this makes it
worse oh wait way worse because it's
that water it's got some pretty [ __ ] in
that way you know
total strangers yeah this this is the
deal
when you
have to have something
you have to have it you don't care
you'll go to but you could have used the
sink water why the toilet water because
i had to go in the
stall
to put it in because otherwise what if
like you know grandma molasses walks in
and there's some
guy sitting there shooting up you didn't
eat at denny's you just shoot up at
denny's right who would eat it exactly
you had to worry about your health
but wait a second i don't understand one
thing so you go there you shoot up you
know in the toilet and the toilet water
and all this kind of stuff but
the fact of the matter is
that
you really are trying to kill yourself
you technically died one time you say in
the book yeah i mean here's the deal
i think that it had gotten so confusing
so insane in my head
that i knew no other way
and it was really sad and you had
everything going for you yeah i mean one
time you said you overdosed a heroin
dealer beat you with a bat to just to
bring you back to life
the other time
when you were hanging out with slash and
his girlfriend
you overdose slash's girlfriend brings
you to the emergency room you didn't
know this you wake up and you say there
could be life after death because you
saw the whole thing you said you were
they said you were technically dead
and you said you saw yourself laying in
bed you saw the hospital room and you
were above the room so do you believe in
life after death pretty pretty close i
mean i it's when i overdosed at the
hotel they put me on the gurney
i had
a
you know later i was like it feels like
i could see the whole thing and i
blurted it out
i blurted it out on uh behind the music
and i was like why did i say that i'm
gonna have to talk about this forever
then when i found the diaries i actually
saw the entries where i was saying i i
don't know what it was but something
something something happened and that
was really when i said i got to clean up
and this is like out of control whether
i hallucinated it or whether i saw it
but it was written down
on a piece of paper so that kind of
freaked me out do i believe in life
after death
you know i'm not sure